all right so welcome to the exciting
part three of our Kings gambit series we
got a got a new one we already got
people shaking their heads alright I
promise this will be the last one though
I keep I keep seeing all sorts of new
variations we could cover but this will
have to do it for that the Kings gambit
for for a good while here either you
like it or you love it
and at least one person in the audience
they never play it so I will do this one
more time
it will move on to something else so we
got a lot of new faces so you guys are
in for for part 3 so you missed the the
first two parts but uh we're going to go
on over tonight the Kings gambit
accepted and tonight we're going to be
going over the main main line so we've
kind of been teasing you with the main
line this whole time and this time we're
actually going to cover it so we're
going to be looking at the move Knight
to f3 and our main focus here is going
to be on the most common move which is
g5 and this is the the main line and we
sort of looked in our first video about
what happens with an early Bishop to c4
and why that is is slightly a dubious
move order so today we'll be looking at
h4 which immediately puts the question
to the jeep on before black has time to
play moves like Bishop to g7 and h6 and
solidify the Kings side and so this will
be our starting point which is the
Kaiser etske gambit and that'll be our
main focus so I did promise that we
would go over in this position Fischer's
defense which is the move d6 which he
calls in a pamphlet he wrote called a
bust to the Kings gambit a high-class
waiting move and the point of the move
d6 is you still want to play the move g5
to protect your pawn but you're
preventing the move Knight to e5 and
it's a kind of fun read so I suggest
that everyone
out there that you goes and you read it
okay it was written a while back so the
analysis isn't as perfect as it is now
in the the modern computer age but he
says some very hilarious stuff so I kind
of want to read a little bit of the the
things that he said in his bus to a
Kings gambit so of this move and he
wrote about the Kings gambit in general
that the Kings gambit has lost
popularity but not sympathy analysts
treat it with kids gloves and seem
reluctant to demonstrate an outright
refutation to just a the opening has
been analyzed romantically not
scientifically modern seem to share the
unconscious attitude that cause
Alzheimer's to curse stubborn stubborn
Steinitz he took the beauty out of chess
so he's saying in the intro to his
pamphlet that uh okay the the Kings
gambit is not something that most people
look at scientifically they don't like
objectively look at it historically it's
been sort of a romantic opening where
people sack wild stuff and they play
sort of dubiously and it all works out
and I do tend to agree with that and
it's it's kind of interesting each
opening sort of has its own feeling to
it and there is something about the
King's gambit that makes people play in
this romantic sacrifice everything for
checkmate style so that's I think a true
statement but so he's trying to say the
King's gambit is refuted and he does
right that he says the refutation of any
gambit begins with accepting it in my
opinion the Kings gambit is busted it
loses by force so he's saying people you
know you've looked at this just kind of
with rose tinted glasses you really like
this opening because of all the wild
attacking games but it's not only
dubious but losing that's his best
Fischer's claim and he analyzes these
lines he talks about Bishop to c4 as his
main line d4 is the more popular move
today but they often transpose and just
to go a few moves further he says h6x
clam like like that's great okay and
okay I mean it's it's probably the most
obvious move but if you've played this
position enough and so we get a position
like this and here he gives as this main
line and let's drag this guy out of the
way Queen to b3 which nowadays is a
super
but I guess that was all the rage back
then this was the main line now it's
like the fifth most popular line and
okay black plays Queen e7 and okay this
is it just become an unpopular line but
he does analyze what is still today the
main line which is g3 and after the
subsequent moves he has further funny
commentary on this position after Knight
to d2 so he says here the strongest move
is Queen to e7 and he says of this move
Bishop to f6
you've a and other analysts betray their
soft mindedness towards this opening by
giving the inferior Bishop to f6 unclear
double exclam and he put unclear in
quotes like that's the the analysts
saying yeah this is unclear and then he
goes on to say too that the pawn on f3
is a bone in White's throat so why force
him to sacrifice it anyway which is what
will typically happen though he does say
also of this position he gets this line
and then he says but black is clearly
winning after the following moves black
does this and he castles and then he
wins so yes a very very interesting
commentary and I also like the famous
line that he gives at the very end of
his thing of course white can play
differently in which case he really
loses differently so that's now that's
become a famous line and perhaps the
biggest criticism I've seen of his work
is that it's like two or three pages so
how could you refute this opening with
such short analysis but it's a really
entertaining read so I'd hope people
that are interested they can go find it
and read it for themselves it makes me
wish Fisher wrote a lot more stuff
because he's funny and he's hard on
people and that's his writing is is
really great but we will return to our
main line today so after Knight to f3
we're going to be looking at lines
involving g5 and so here's is it this is
the main line the kind of a risky gambit
and we're going to look at the three
most popular moves in this position
the most popular move is Knight to f6
the Berlin defense I will also take a
look at D 6 which is the coalition
defense and we're going to look at the
the opening with perhaps the coolest
name of the knight the long whip defense
so black creates this long whip with his
pawns and having played this opening now
for about 3 weeks because we're three
weeks into this I've noticed this
actually is a popular variation online
but it doesn't have a very good
reputation so obviously this is black
saying I'm going to take the pawn and
I'm just going to keep it and solidify
my pawns and usually black tries to be
as greedy as possible
which is something they used to do back
in the 1800s
one person would gambit stuff and get
all their pieces out and check make the
other person but that another person
would you know try to hold on to all of
their stuff and over the time we sort of
learned that this greed isn't always
good especially in the Kings gambit so
it's usually better to get your pieces
out so when we get to the main line
we'll see okay you get your pieces out
and then you get a good game and okay
what you do normally in this opening
sort of the point of why would you have
your night out here so early
obviously d6 is going to kick it away in
the near future but it does have the
point that you're looking at f7 which is
the main focal point so Bishop to c4 and
black has to think about how he's going
to defend the f7 pawn so in this
position already there's two main ways
of defending it so defending what the
Queen doesn't really do anything but the
two main ways of defending are perhaps
the most obvious Knight to h6 and the
less obvious and funnier rook to h7 so
finally black develops a piece and it's
a rook so it's hard to think of any
other game where you move your rook
first but this actually is seen here in
our future game I'll show you a game
with Braunstein where this move was
played and the point is you're keeping
the h6 Square free so that you can put
your bishop here
and defend your f-pawn that's the point
so but first let's take a look at the
more popular move which is Knight to h6
all right and we've we've doubled the
number of quarries in our audience so
we're doing pretty good doing pretty
good mmm
okay Knight to h6 this is the more
common move it defends the F pawn and
effort loops d 4 and D 6 the knight
doesn't have a good sacrifice on f7 so
it goes back and we're about to win the
pawn on f4 so this is a typical
defensive resource that black has in
these types of positions instead of just
letting the pawn fall black plays f3 and
with this ok he's trying to keep the
Kings side closed and black just needs
to catch up in development and a typical
line would be after Bishop to e7
threatening the H pawn Bishop e3 so that
when you take we can put our King here
on d2 outside of the Bishop and it's a
it's a very interesting position so this
is sort of what you might expect when
you play this that the long stock
variation as long whip variation is this
sort of thing and there was a Morphy
game where black made a big mistake more
if you actually put his Bishop on f4 but
black made the big mistake of taking
here which was disastrous for him
because once white took back he put
stuff on the F file and really bad
things happened really quickly but this
is sort of the the main line of this
this variation but let's let's look at
this game and this is actually the game
between David Bronstein and a player
named Peter Dubin in who was in niam and
a correspondence grandmaster so he's
very good at correspondence back in the
days before you could just use your
computers so if you're a grandmaster and
correspondence today it means you're
really good at using computers which
which is usually allowed so okay so use
it was a decently strong player but
Braunstein this was played in 1947 which
was when Bronstein was
particularly good and he was known for
his aggressive attacking style so an
opening like this is something you could
expect from him and his opponent played
really really greedily so we'll see in
this position so after up to h7d for so
now if d6 we can either take on f7 or we
can go back to d3 also we're attacking
the F pawn and so this was sort of the
point of your your rook move here which
you're going to put the bishop on h6
that's why you can put a knight there it
is also possible to play the move d6
which is a little more common and is
likely to be similar to the variation we
saw just a moment ago where after f3 we
take and now they can attack our pond so
we move our Bishop and our King goes
here and you get this sort of unusual
position where white should be a little
bit better alright but in this game
Bishop to h6 okay so he says he wants
everything I want the pond I want it all
and so white just calmly develops and so
after either Knight to c6 or d6 White
had the same thing in mind now putting
the knight on d3 doesn't make as much
sense because your d4 pawn is not
protected so he just goes for it he
takes on f7 okay
so after some captures already there's a
tactic for white in the King's gambit
who would have thought so what did white
play in this position I guess we'll get
the audience how did this audience grow
so much so fast
we started with nobody now we have like
a full class this is great excellent
Bishop takes f4 and the point is
hopefully everybody can see it after he
takes back White Castle and black
decided just to go for the pawn which is
okay there was a game that also saw this
greedy move where it's I'm just going to
protect my bishop and keep it forever
but this fails to e5 and let's
okay maybe I'll just go to h6 keep my
guy protected and but this also just
fails due to Queen to d2 attacking the
pins piece so obviously we can't take
the Queen and this should be very good
for white so he probably saw that he's a
pretty greedy guy but I guess he wasn't
that greedy
so he took here and okay looks a little
bit scary but who was it scarier for so
white takes here and so it looks like
white has black has two pieces for the
rook so black is up a small margin of
material here but you'll notice these
guys aren't doing so much he's sort of
in a bad way and white could play the
immediate Knight to d5 it's a very good
choice here but he did something that
good players like to do he used all of
his pieces so he just played Queen to d2
with the idea of bringing his last rook
into the game and putting some pressure
here on f7 and it's it's not really
obvious that black can do a whole lot to
stop it black is already in a really bad
way just due to the fact that white's
pieces are so active so after d6 he
brought the rook over now it's a good
indication that black is probably losing
when you see blacks next move and it's
the computer move so but still if you
have to play Knight to d8 you're you're
probably losing it's not often you see a
knight on d8 obviously it has the point
that now rook f7 is a blunder but now
you're you're just not going to use any
of these pieces at all so it doesn't
matter that you're up one point of
material when you don't use any of your
material and your opponent uses
everything all right so he got his
knight into the game and black played
Bishop to d7 and he should probably be
hoping that white takes on c7 because
then the knight is going in the wrong
direction and then the rook comes to c8
maybe the route gets active so obviously
he has no intention of just going to win
the pawn that's that's clearly not the
point of his play but he needs to find
it
to increase his activity so I will go
ahead and I'll ask the audience who can
find the move the white played in this
position
yeah I'm looking at Kuni three and then
five might be fine mm-hmm yeah so the
suggestion was Queen III followed by e5
which does make sense but yeah he did go
for it right away
so yeah he's just opening up the game as
much as possible and black took so white
took back okay very good and now black
decided to play Bishop to c6
so his idea presumably is just to take
the knight and reduce the amount of
material but okay that alone might not
be be a hold enough to help black here
okay and he continued to play very
actively so in this position ecigs goes
so he's getting control over f7 this
ones have been possible if the bishop
were still here
because then we could take this so he
takes advantage of the fact let's turn
this volume off all right for Ben Simon
we'll keep it there just in case I make
some more mistakes
you'll get to hear it how about make a
mistake I can't even make mistakes okay
so you have access to f7 again and so
obviously if the knight takes then we
get to put a rock on f7 so instead white
sorry black took the night and now the
game is nice and wide open we have
diagonals to the King we have access to
f7 but are pawns attack don't know so
what did white play in this position
and I probably wouldn't ask if it was
Queen takes bishop though that should be
winning too
Queen d4 is also winning and so is Queen
here like everything wins but in the
game rook f7 alright sacrificing so
we're thinking about checkmate here so
he takes we take back with the rook
alright King goes back in the corner and
now
queen d3 you're threatening checkmate
alright and this does nothing I don't
have at least a perpetual no right maybe
I don't but I've at least this move I
mean you can come back and block well
yeah we have their idea right you want
to get that Queen into the action
involved with the rook yeah you're down
to just two pieces so you got a awesome
yeah all right we got Queen c3 which is
just as good as Queen d4 but it's
farther away which is kind of cool so
we're not interested in your bishop
we're here just to win material you
don't have a lot of options so you have
to block on f6 either with the knight or
the Queen so he went with his knight but
uh the game is now over after here he
played the computer move Queen takes
rook okay resigning was also a good
option in this position and black played
a few more moves so he just went he took
this and now is the time to resign so
and I'm not before this okay so a great
illustration though here of what can
happen all the time in the King's gambit
one side is really really greedy we take
the pawn we try to hold it for way too
long but what really matters in these
positions the most is the quality of the
pieces and and your piece activity so a
really good display of the things that
can happen when black just holds on to
everything and white gets all of his
pieces out and checkmates his opponent
so alright very excellent game we'll
we'll look at some more
all right and this time we'll flip the
board so we've shown a lot of games that
are good for white but eventually in
this dubious opening we'll have to show
some games for black so we have it again
the King's gambit accepted and we get
the main line so in this position we'll
look at the other two moves both which
have a very good reputation will show
one more game a more recent game in the
coalition variation and before that
we'll go ahead and we'll have a main a
look at the the main move here
the Berlin defense which is you know one
of the one of the best ways so unlike
all the suspicious openings in the main
line you develop your pieces so we'll
look at good play for a change and okay
so the sort of the point of having your
knight on e5 is to target the f7 pawn
and how does black stop you from just
taking on f7 and winning immediately
yeah d5 so if you take with the bishop
I'll play Knight takes bishop
so why typically takes with the pond and
the main move here is Bishop d6 asking
your your knight what he wants to do now
the main line is d4 which is the most
solid way to play and it appears that
I've lost all of my analysis oh no but
in this line we'll come back to the more
exciting line the rice gambit which is
to simply castle and leave your knight
on free will come to that which is is
you know typically Wilder which is
saying something because even this
variation is pretty crazy but only if I
can remember it so in this position
typically you guard your F pawn and okay
so you guarded this guy but now you're G
pawns hanging I mean okay so this
usually happens and white takes here
which okay threatens some discoveries
followed by Queen takes h5 so you play
here which threatens the knight for a
second time
and when they go away you play here you
get a line like this which is very
complicated obviously and to play this
way you sort of need to know a whole lot
about this variation so it's something
that you would probably want to be well
prepared for which is probably why at
the amateur level it doesn't occur so
often so I've just been playing hundreds
of blitz games in this and people seem
to rarely accept it because you need to
know a whole lot and they don't face the
King's gambit very often but it also
makes me feel like I should keep playing
the King's gambit cuz nobody knows what
to do and then you just get good
positions right away they never play the
critical stuff you they just like I want
to learn that and then you get good
positions and I'm going to keep playing
it okay but those are the main line but
even more exciting and more dubious is
back in this position to play the rice
gambit which is just a castle not
defending the knight the point being
when to take the knight we have some
efile tricks here
okay Queenie seven which might look kind
of scary right because you're putting
your queen on the same file here as the
rooks your queen and king are lined up
with the rook on the e-file
usually this spells big disaster but
here actually gives black a little bit
more time to get on with some of the
moves that he wants to play and the
problem for white is the immediate d4
which might look crushing at first sight
just doesn't work because what does
black play
yeah Bishop takes d4 so obviously if you
take my bishop with your Queen I take
your rook but if white things are at I'm
clever all right now the joke is back on
you I just moved my king instead well
then you just play Bishop to e3 and okay
black is crushing it here
so instead c3 preparing d4 and now we
preemptively protect the F pawn so we
know d4 is coming so we gotta what are
we going to do about that
well we'll defend it just so you don't
take back with your rook now if you take
it back with your rook I take it and
every human here has played an inferior
move but it seems like all humans agree
in this position you pin the night so
you're once again threatening rook to e5
but perhaps the most critical though
untested is a crazy move Queen takes g4
which lines the Queen up with the bishop
and it opens the G file but perhaps the
best is just to take on d4 with the same
idea and now the Queen and rook are
lined up but since it's it's check we
get to move here and say let's see what
what black should play here yeah Knight
to g3 forcing white to play his only
move which is to take tonight
and after some complicated training we
get a position like this where blacks
should be better based on the fact that
his pieces will reach more active
squares and it's actually white that has
more pawn weaknesses here so you can
imagine rook to g8 to g4 with pressure
on these ponds although also I mean of
course White has his own activity as
well but okay there should be be quite
good for black alright so we'll return
now
all right so we return now to this
position and we'll look at the game
between Alexi fedorov and Alexi Shirov
so the battle of the Alexie's so white
is a 2,600 player and black as a 2700
player so okay so a very high-level
fight and for some reason I see sheer of
in playing the King's gambit as both
sides in the database but he's perhaps
somebody you don't want to play the
Kings gambit against he seems he seems
to win pretty handily when he's on the
black side he's you know famous for his
tactics and his his fire on the board so
when you play this way you know
sometimes he just crushes you he's very
good in these types of positions and he
chose the colas
which should equalize very easily for
black which is well one of the main
reasons why people don't play this way
as white very often at the top top level
okay my Knights attacked I'll take your
Jeep on and now Knight to f6 and already
his opponent played rather passively and
he's a pretty good opponent
Fedorov is sort of an expert in the
Kings gambit he's played it a hundred
times as white he's had won all sorts of
brilliant games with it but this wasn't
one of them in this game he chose to go
all the way back to f2 and he got into
some trouble immediately the more common
move is to take on f6 which is kind of
an indication that white is already
thinking about trying to equalize the
position so black gets his pieces out
and in general black will get is his
pieces out a little bit faster than
white and the fact you have doubled
pawns isn't really a huge issue and it
even gives you the G file so a line like
this would occur and after this move
blacks move might surprise you the main
main theoretical move here because I
think a lot of people would just grab
their Queen and go back to d8 defend
their C pawn but you can even play the
move Queen to g6
and white will play a move like d3 and
you'll you'll get this sort of as the
main starting position
but to understand why let's let's take
this alright so you got to move your
king and if we're really greedy what is
black gonna play alright Ben Simon's on
the board Queen g3 and now for the big
dispute
I showed this position to Danny Machuca
and I said you can checkmate this way or
this way which one is more attractive
and we couldn't agree so I'll pull the
audience who thinks Knight to d4 is the
more attractive checkmate
all right we got like three hands all
right what about Bishop to g4 who for
who I guess I guess Danny was right all
along
people the people have spoken is Bishop
to g4 I quite liked the knight move I
thought the other move was a little bit
more obvious because it's a skewer so I
kind of like the knight move and he made
fun of me he's like oh you just moved
the same pieces you got to use all your
pieces okay
so that was the important position of
the lecture but now we'll go back and
we'll look at the move that was actually
played in this game which was Knight - f
- all right so we got Knight to f2 here
on the board
okay so rook to g8 which is kind of
annoying because now it's really
difficult to develop this bishop
anywhere so why play d4 very sensible
and now we protect our pawn which is
sort of a typical thing you might seem
odd to put your your Bishop over on the
side but this is a really annoying pawn
we don't want to just give up the pawn
for free so it's very typical in these
lines to defend it with your Bishop and
after a couple more developing moves
white played a move there was one of the
top computer choices but if you keep
playing this through this whole line
they both played like the computer lines
and then eventually the computers like
Oh Black's winning
so white played a move that looks pretty
good and the computer is like yeah
that's pretty good but then if you keep
going
five ten moves down the line it's like
Oh whites already losing so you know not
easy to see but it's black to move here
I guess I'll start letting you guys play
like sure of what would you guys play
here is black it sound like a brilliant
tactic or anything it's just though just
a move all right so in this position he
took the knight on d5 and white took
back and okay before moving the night he
threw this check in and white defended
with the bishop which obviously
undefended the Jeep on but if you defend
with the Queen we can either trade on e2
and then take on d4 or we can take on d4
right away and this isn't a very
pleasant position for white we have some
threats going on here and our pieces are
coming in very quickly so this wasn't
chosen instead he defended with the
bishop but it might seem like okay so I
had two undefended take care of that
after you take care of your knight but
what are you going to do are you really
going to go to be four alright so he did
all right you know just kind of strange
what are you doing out there because now
I play c4 and I'm gonna check you and
win your knight so that's that's White's
threat but black said bring it on
and he played Bishop to f5 a very strong
move obviously I mean if you don't check
and win my knight then I'm going to see
two so what are you going to do so he
did it he gets off the e-file now he can
bring his other rook over to e8 and so
after this capture rook to e8 and what
is under an incredible amount of
pressure now so he fell for the trap
but now he's completely winning okay
yeah when sheriff falls for the trap
normally that's a bad sign for you
okay so here yeah just all of blacks
pieces are great and these guys are not
great you're not so good either neither
are you or you or you you're not good
either so but you got some good pods
here those guys are pretty good all
right and all the blacks pieces are just
all over you so here he took with lots
of threats like lots and if you put this
on the computer we had to go down like
how many moves can black play that like
when and it's like 15 moves you know I
okay like this move wins and this move
wins and this wins and like every move
wins but among your threats the biggest
one is perhaps Queen takes h4 you can't
take with your rook because then I drop
down to g1 and also F 3 is a pretty
serious threat you can take my bishop
with Czech but I'll move over to g8 and
then you've got a lot of problems and
obviously the positional threat of a5
stopping b4 but okay that's that's not a
the main thing so you kind of got to get
off of this out of this pin attack the
rook and I've shown this position to a
lot of people and they don't play the
right move here which seems kind of
strange now it's not a brilliant move he
just put his rook back and which is fine
it's also possible to put your bishop
here immediately he puts it there just a
second all right so now maybe you'll get
your Bishop out and black here now
decide to play Bishop to e4
so obviously if you if you go here I'm
taking on h4 which is a pretty big issue
so he stays on his pawn and now a very
strong move we would like to have
another one of these pieces over here so
we'd be making some threats
so f5 giving the Queen access to have
seven which is very annoying white
decided to take and another added bonus
is now we can take back with a pawn in
our pawns are very strong so we're
thinking you're out playing f3 or e3 and
you're just really strangled here is
white you just don't have any good moves
here
he put his Bishop here and then after e3
shutting down this guy which locks out
that guy ah you move this Bishop again
and yeah things are things are pretty
bad but let's say so Queen g7 and now
after this move which isn't the best but
Manus it's hard to play white black
played one more move here and then the
game ended
so you go ahead you can pause your video
at home it's a nice little move I guess
it's not the greatest act of all time
but it's a nice move okay hopefully some
of you were able to find this at home
rook to g2 you know just with a nice
idea that if you take with the bishop we
can play the move e - winning everything
so here white it had enough it says he's
been tortured long enough so he just
gave it up here so a very strong example
of good preparation presumably by Alexei
shear of and how quickly you can get
into trouble playing this way as white
especially if black is well-prepared
if black knows what he's doing and he
plays the critical lines he's usually at
least either equal or winning in most of
the main lines so that's why people
don't play it at the top level because
their opponents are well-prepared and
then you just lose so but uh returning
to what Fischer said it is sort of in
the spirit of the opening to play sort
of romantically with this opening so I
would recommend that people do take a
serious look at it it is a lot of fun
you do see lots of brilliant and
beautiful games so I'd take the risk
play the Kings gambit it's a lot of fun
and as always hit like share subscribe
and tell me what do you think what do
you think about the King's gambit and
what do you guys want to see next week
all right thanks everybody
you
you